so basically
let me talk to you about a furore that
you're involved in last year because i
found it very interesting the way the
debate played out you wrote an op-ed for
market watch yes a year ago actually in
which you said that the american flag no
longer represents democracy and freedom
you wanted it changed
why
well i i just think that uh it's it's a
it's like you know in a general thing
it's just a new day it's time that you
know you reboot the constitution the
flag all the all the old standards you
know that that our ancestors lived by
you know were right for for the time
they lived in but we're in a different
time you know so um
so the flag is uh so in the states you
know to me what the stakes do best
is diversity it's culture you know what
i mean without culture in america you
really don't have
much going on you know you have you know
i don't know amazon like what do you
have if you don't have color in the
states i mean i agree with that what i
would say to you is though that
it's such a divisive issue things like
the flag do you not think there's a
danger i'm interested in what how you
feel a year on from that debate you got
hammered obviously by a lot of people a
lot of americans were outraged others
thought you raised an interesting point
in a way it wasn't that dissimilar to
what colin kaepernick went through with
the protests that he was doing some
agreed with him others were furious do
you have any regrets about the what you
said about the flag
no in fact i'm excited to bring it up
again because i i think it's more
important now what what i want to do is
is more important now it's just
messaging it's just
it's just like if you if you
so my idea was to make the stars
the colors of all of us so they'll be a
star representing you one representing
me one representing everybody in the
room right so that way you look up to
the flag and you feel welcome you feel
included you feel like you belong there
why does okay let me play devil's
advocate yeah which is i think the
american flag is a fantastic flag i love
my flag here too the english flag the uk
flag i love these flags
to me they're not about
making any kind of diverse point they're
just great flags and if i was an
american most americans i've spoken to
about this they say
there are other ways to to celebrate
diversity juneteenth is one right right
there are other ways to do this why go
after such a
powerful emblem of the united states of
america when it causes the whole debate
actually a lot of disunity whenever the
flag was was was conceptualized they
they made it based off what was going on
during that time which was a war that's
another thing we celebrate
a flag that represents war i actually
have an american flag on my office wall
at home yeah
i think we've got a we've got a picture
of it
um i think i look that's my office wall
uh in london
uh i look at that every day uh it's
actually quite a unique one it's got 34
stars yes which means it was actually
the flag from the civil war period when
lincoln was president and that's the
only flag that was in use during
lincoln's presidency and i bought it at
an auction because america's been a
large part of my life and i i find it a
stirring
emblem but i never look at it and think
well that's about
white people or you know white power
over black people or that's attacking
diversity or it could be more diverse i
just think it's such a magnificent
emblem now i'm white so i might think
that
well it's not it's not that it's about
white people it's it's just that our
everything is different than when
lincoln was president so
and whoever designed that flag designed
it for that day
so i'm just saying what's wrong with the
new flag what's wrong with
representing where where we are now like
we no longer have 34 states right right
so they made one with 50 states well
then they've changed the flag over the
years that's true
when you got kicked back on this yeah
did it surprise you how ferocious some
of it was did you mine did you expect it
no i didn't expect it i thought people
would agree with me
i thought people like yeah let's let's
do a new flag i don't know it's kind of
an art project it's just like well i
don't see why not that's my thing do you
feel that more people are aware of
racial injustice of racial equality do
you feel like they're taking the knee
which went around the world
like wildfire especially after george
floyd was killed do you feel that that
all helps or are these just
token things which don't actually make
any tangible difference
um i i think it made a lot of people
aware i think when it comes to
changing someone's view on race or
people uh that's that's more than a one
event that's that's
you know that's growing up that's
parenting that's where you go to school
that's what neighborhood you live in
there's a lot that goes into how you
feel about people that aren't like you
you know what i mean do you feel that
america is more or less racist than when
you grew up it's definitely not as bad
you know uh i was born in the 60s so i
don't understand racism be honest with
you i like i get like i'm sitting here
with you
and we're different you know what i mean
and there might be things that i i would
be i wouldn't want to say in front of
you that i might say in front of my
friends of color and vice versa
but like to hate someone or want to kill
someone or
hold somebody down because of what they
look like i don't i don't understand i
mean i completely agree i think i think
most people would completely agree with
that i do think racism is a is a
minority fortunately in almost every
country and particularly america and
britain i don't think it's it by any
means a popular thing but it exists
and it's the it's what's the best way to
tackle it what's the best way to get rid
of it you have to let go of uh
needing to be better than than everyone
else you have to let go of
of of your hang-ups about slavery you
have to let go of your hang-ups about
superiority you have to you know it's
very personal how you feel about other
people you know
like we could have a conversation about
how you feel about women you know and
then there would be so many things that
that went into that you know i mean
we're in an era now basically you can't
most public figures are too terrified to
even say what they think a woman is i
know i mean what if i asked you what a
woman is what would you say
i would say a human being with boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just is a human adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that now
that's a little getting confusing the
whole he
they that's good that's good and i'm not
sure why really it's it's a bit like
this whole issue of transgenders in
sport it's like i support all trans
rights to fairness and equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at their sport i totally agree and
i will say this and everybody's gonna
hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you or her i will because
that's what you want but that doesn't
make you a woman just cause i call you
or her and just because you got a
surgery because people do
feel that you there's biological sex and
then there's gender identity that you
can identify as whatever you like in
terms of agenda right that's the freedom
we live in but actually you can't change
the mechanics of biological sex they are
what they are
well just every like women go through
just a completely unique experience
and and surgery or
you know finding yourself doesn't
doesn't change that you know being a a
little girl is is a whole
epic book you know
and and you can't you can't have that
just because you want to be a woman i
mean you know when people like jk
rowling have said this
they get attacked they get abused
the canceled culture mob comes from me
she gets called transphobic and so on
you might get the same for saying it but
it's the truth i'm not i i know and
and and and i don't think you should be
called transphobic just because you
don't agree
with you know i i just there's a lot of
you know
judgment and throwing you know stones at
people for for just saying what it is
you know what i mean
you have hung out with some very
interesting people in your time yeah
prince was one of them you sat in a dark
room
he called me onto his room the lights
were out which was weird and you talked
for two hours in this dark room yeah and
he gave you a great bit of advice do you
remember it
yes he said uh just remember it's not
about you what do you mean by that that
as an artist it's about what you give
what you how you make your fans feel i
read recently that you're you're looking
for love
well you know that's that's that's
subjective that's you know
that could mean a lot of things
well what did you mean by it what did i
mean i don't know
i don't know you know i haven't been in
a relationship in a while and i just
kind of picture myself uh you know
doing all that right now because it's a
lot of work and i don't see it yet but
i'm thinking when i do i'm just going to
have a an audition really
yeah i'm just going to like have a
cattle call and i get to shoot
did i say that wrong i have a man called
a cattle call yeah i'll pick the ones
you know a lot of balls turn up is that
the idea yeah
and then i'll enter interview them
and then i'll
and just to give them a bit of help
before they join the queue and it'll be
a i'm sure a very extensive line but
what advice would you give them about
the kind of man you're looking for
oh gosh
see that's that's long okay let me think
well you know just not to be corny but
there's energy you know there's
connection there's like you look at
someone and you you know
it's that thing
energy yes energy you know you're
comfortable with someone told smold you
can't sure talk happening
yeah how tall are you six one oh plenty
of energy you're married
she'll probably she'll probably trade me
she's probably watching
but no but
but uh yeah definitely tall because i'm
tom 5 11. how many how many times have
you actually been properly in love in
your life do you think well i've been
married twice so that's two plus maybe
two more
four times it's difficult yeah to get to
go there you know well hard to be also
when you're as successful as you are
thank you and you're famous thank you
and you're doing all this and you're
being messy great it's hard to then have
a human relationship right where you can
i guess completely trust people
uh no i don't i don't have i'm not a big
i don't trust and i don't really worry
about that i just uh it's just a comfort
thing for me you know who i can sit with
and then be myself at least you know
most of the time when you came out with
your criticism of the american flag you
did also i think make it clear that you
were proud to be an american very i
loved by the country probably more than
most of the people who criticize me
right yeah i was going to ask you that
no i love my country i'm proud of my
country
i'm proud of where i'm from of you know
being a woman being black i love
everybody i can honestly say i love
everybody
and if i could have the power to let you
relive one moment in your entire
life yeah
outside of having your kids and getting
married what would you choose
boy
let's see
there's days in the week when i lay in
my bed in my underwear and i switch
channels and i don't have any and i'm
not worried about anything and they're
the best those are the best
and i just go through my channels and i
find something and i don't have to get
up and go to peers morgan i'm sorry i
could just lie here
[Laughter]
those are the best moments you know do
you sing when you're on your own you
just suddenly let rip
uh i do you know i i do i do start
singing yeah sometimes because i'm still
like i said working on my voice i'm
trying to get to a thing you know that
i'm working on so i have a song called
uh every night but you've got to hear
that should actually be the the theme
it's out now yeah i know that yeah from
the new album the reset congratulations
and then i have a song called thinking
of you because okay i am drinking and i
am thinking of you
and were you thinking of me when you
sang them totally
[Laughter]
absolutely
macy it's great to see you uh the new
album the reset is on uh released on
july 8th your new single every night is
out now you just finished your uk tour
and you're on your on tour in america
now yes well best of luck with it thank
you lovely to see you thanks for having
me